[Music]
these are the amount of footage that
we've recorded for the past two years
and you're probably wondering to
yourself gee zaki that's a lot of
storage and yes it is and just like you
business professionals and creatives
like myself hard drive failure is the
last thing you want in any given point
in time just imagine you finish
recording your video wrangled the data
put it in the hard drive send it to the
editor
and boom you are essentially what they
call um
[Music]
so i took it upon myself to find the
best alternative solution to my storage
problem and this
is what i found
this is the wd my passport ssd
what's up everybody zeki here from geek
culture and in this video we'll be
taking a look at why you should be
getting a portable ssd and a portable
ssd is even worth it
stay tuned
with hundreds of hours of footage that
we've done here in geek culture there's
simply no room for errors and some of
you out there who are watching this
video will probably have faced a similar
situation corrupted drives the drives
are simply just not working or they're
probably just too old the main problem
here is that hard drives tend to fail
because they have only about three to
five years of a lifespan whether it's a
portable hard drive or an internal hard
drive it's pretty much the same thing
and the fact that solid-state drives
tend to be a rising trend among pc
owners you can pretty much say goodbye
to the old and say hello to the new guys
on the block put it simply
solid state drives much faster
better
they last longer and
it pretty much outperforms a typical
hard drive and boy this thing is fast
how fast one might ask
[Music]
it's blazing for us
with transfer speeds of up to 1050
megabytes per second this ssd might be
able to keep up with the flash
with its stylish slim body as well as
its overall metal casing on top of that
the western digital my passport ssd is
built like a tank
featuring shock and vibration resistance
of up to 1.98 meters or 6 and a half
feet so the main question here is is
this even for me
well portable ssds such as this one like
the western digital my passport solid
state drive is proven to be an
affordable choice
while remaining something very stylish
doable and compact that's so easy to
bring around it's also one that
transfers files faster than speedy
gonzales
talk about fast going
fast
okay whether it's from a performance or
value for money point of view you can
expect the western digital my passport
solid-state drive to be your go-to
storage device
for a very very very long time
[Music]